j'avais tout faux
[Applaudissements]
alors aulas
elle fait partie jeudi des heurts au
chat et à la caisse si je ne l'aimais
pas les des garçons de salle et je vis
ces cas sont encore et paraguay c'est
génial on bosse on bosse on lit
marcel proulx ya quoi y'a martin alors
shy'm vous ce que j'aime chez vous c'est
que vous chantez bien vous danser bien
et en plus vous êtes sexy en toute
circonstance non mais c'est vrai
toujours sexy ça veut dire que scheibel
en train de kara clafoutis elle sort le
truc dufour a laissé que vous faites la
cuisine où passe pas souvent on a
souvent mangé se connaissent pas se bat
souvent moi je sais pas la clinique pour
soi même c'est pas super dont on
s'entendait d'amis et oui médias parce
qu'elle est libre ne s'est pas
d'arranger pour mon homme le soir tout
les jeux vous alors donnez lui markine
un amour de poids les volants vous sans
manger il y aura un petit peu alors ça
j'ai offert une interview sexy c'est à
dire je vous parlais de choses pas du
tout sexy et on va devoir tous les deux
être très sexy pendant cette interview
d'accord les femmes avant de commencer
ce que vous êtes chaude pour cette
interview shy'm a lieu c'est
complètement chaude c'est assez énorme
il y avait quoi je t'aime je t'aime bah
écoutez je ne demandais pas tant
[Applaudissements]
ça je le sens bien ça allégé de paris
peut prévenir les chéris je vais
demander à tous les garçons de passer
devant biens sous l'autorité
attention c'est parti c'est vieux c'est
pire
les si vous êtes arrivé en septembre qui
attendent qu'on bosse sept corps et en
modern'jazz
je vous ai tout appris la chaille là tu
me fais un peu 3,4 alors que je t'avais
dit que c'était un deux trois quatre
cinq six sept minutes
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'allemagne
[Applaudissements]
vous allez bientôt partir en tournée oh
oui c'est bon les tournées ce qui est
vous vous moquez tu vas là qu'est ce qui
va vous manquer le plus quand vous serez
sur la route
pas grand chose j'attends ça depuis
depuis un an à four chaud sexy l'omi oui
et non oui elle va partir sur la route
j'espère qu'elle va croiser blake n
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
qu'est ce que ça fait c'est jean genet
le pas de calais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes loin
[Applaudissements]